did you develop the cleft and the
jawline from years of badassery or did
you just come out of the womb
with this oh i got issued that once i
joined these
just give you a buzz cut like a kiss
from a badass angel
really excited to have our next guest on
because uh his book is actually a book
we handed out as a handbook here at
lotto with crowder for people and new
hires it is extreme ownership
he's one of the co-authors of this uh he
also has the jocko
podcast at jacopodcast.com you can
follow him at jocko willink
retired lieutenant navy seal more medals
than we can mention brazilian jiu jitsu
black belt
also founder i want to make sure i get
this right echelon
echelon front front front leadership
firm consulting firm he does so much
it's incredible but this book is
something that's really been uh pivotal
to this team
jacob thank you for being on the show
sir thanks for having me on
i well i'm very glad to have you on
you're an intimidating character so i
hope this goes well and i get on your
good side
um for those who haven't yet read the
book yet to be determined
yes to be determined and usually it
doesn't bode well for me
um for those who haven't yet read the
book uh meaning people not in a lot of
crowded company and i highly recommend
it can you can can you help them
understand define what extreme ownership
means
yeah so extreme ownership is the
attitude
it's the mindset that you're not going
to blame anyone else or anything else
when something goes wrong you're
actually going to take
ownership of whatever that problem is
and you're going to get that problem
fixed
and i know it sounds relatively simple
but it's actually pretty hard for people
to do
so why do you think it is hard for
people to do like what would be some
prime examples of that for people you
know
not the navy seal crowd more so the
stay-at-home crowd
well one of the hardest things about
taking ownership
when things go wrong is you have an ego
and you don't want to admit that
something is your fault and what you'd
rather do
as a human being is just blame other
people or blame the circumstances or
blame the market
or blame anything else yeah and when
when all you do is sit around and blame
other people and other things then guess
what that problem doesn't go away
it just usually gets worse right so
that's the that's the idea of extreme
ownership there's something going wrong
i'm going to take ownership it's my
responsibility i'm gonna get it fixed
and even the truth is and i think you
talk about this in the book sometimes it
is somebody else's fault but it doesn't
help you because you can't control them
and you talk about ego quite a bit and
funny thing is i i actually came to know
you
through some interviews about brazilian
jiu jitsu i don't know how i stumbled
across you but you were talking about
sort of combat arts
versus some of the uh i guess shall we
say less effective martial arts but it
was very respectful but i could read
between the lines
um you talk quite a bit about ego when
you discuss the combat sports side and
we've had
joe rogan on daniel cormier just last
week
tim kennedy they talk a lot about how
ego clouds it destroys can you
define that a little more clearly for
people who may not know when you're
talking about ego and how to avoid that
specifically
yeah well the problem with ego is if
you've got a big ego
and and i'm not talking about having no
ego because if you have ego if you're
daniel cormier
you got to think that you're going to be
the champion you've got to think you
have to believe that you can make it
happen
but you have to counter that with some
level of humility
where you say you know what i'm not the
best in the world i'm the the person
that i'm gonna be fighting
is gonna be awesome and i've gotta be at
my best game so what does that
mean that means i have to train hard
that
i means to do everything in my power to
be ready for this fight if people lack
humility
then they say oh i don't need to train
hard because i'll be able to i'll be
able to beat this guy anyways and then
guess what they get beat
yeah it happens all the time we had
george champion the show and he talked
about how he was terrified before every
fight and daniel cormier said that in
his mind
he was going through excuses right
before miocic of why he should lose that
fight you know
he's 255 pounds i'm really a
middleweight he said that he was very
candid on the show
which is something else that i noticed
with really successful people having
been blessed enough to interview people
at the top of their field
once they get there they tend to be
candid you have the exceptions to the
rule
but they tend to be transparent because
i don't know that they have a lot of
time
not to be um let me ask you this how do
you differentiate then this is a tough
question we've talked about this on the
program
how to differentiate between ego and a
realistic assessment of your abilities
particularly if you have abilities that
are greater than average
well i'll tell you right now most people
that are that end up in a position where
they're greater than average
they're not sitting around saying oh i'm
the bra i'm the greatest in the world
they're like daniel cormier saying you
know what i could i could lose this
fight they're like george st
pierre paranoid and scared before every
fight the guys that think they're just
gonna win every single fight
they're they're they're the ones that
end up getting caught earlier in their
career and even somebody that comes
across
as having a massive ego like like conor
mcgregor
if you watch how conor mcgregor uh
actually trains yeah he's training
like he wants to be the best he knows
he's got weaknesses
in his game and he steps up to cover
those weaknesses yeah there's a
difference between
selling fights and you know your
lifestyle uh
let me ask you this where do you think
the line is between you kind of
mentioned like george st
pierre fear almost a little bit of
paranoia where's the line especially as
someone who's in the military
and obviously you're afraid when you're
going into a firefight and you could die
where's the line between fear paranoia
and using it so it's productive
so there's there's definitely a
difference between fear and respect
and i i wasn't afraid of the enemy but i
respected the enemy and i realized that
they could do some things that could
surprise us and catch us off guard
and that's something you have to deal
with if you don't respect the enemy
which i guess you know if you're not
afraid of the enemy at all if you don't
if you just think you can dominate the
enemy
well then you start cutting quarters you
don't train as hard you don't prepare as
much when you do that you're going to
lose
yeah you see that with almost every
great fighter right the tail end of
their career isn't usually their age
you look at guys like mike tyson the
tail end of their careers usually they
just they get complacent
um i think a lot of people miss it they
think oh he got old and you look at me
like well actually
he was 35 he was 35 at this point not
mike tyson specifically but it happens a
lot and they just get to you know get to
a point it's i think it was jeff danaher
who said
it's hard to get out of bed at six in
the morning when you're getting out of
silk sheets
i'm like oh okay that that sort of
crystallizes that perfectly
um now the same thing happens to
businesses too you know businesses that
you know because we work with businesses
all the time and
as the business grows and they start to
feel like oh
we're going to crush the competition the
competition can't touch us and then the
next thing you know there's someone
that's younger some business than some
company that's smaller and they're
younger and they're hungrier
and they're working their tails off yeah
if you're sitting on the top of the hill
you don't think you need to work anymore
next thing you know you're getting eaten
yeah it's it's a good point it's
happened right now with late night you
know great example you've seen these
late night wars and people become so
complacent just take their audience for
granted
and then all of a sudden it fractures
and uh we draft in right behind them we
have no business doing it but
we're doing okay and i think that's
actually a big difference between a job
in the military and employees who often
might read this book in the civilian
workforce is um the ability
to ignore something if it's not on your
item list right you see that a lot if
it's not my job description well
it's not my fault whereas in special
forces in the military if you do that
you
you could die and i know you talk about
primarily leading by example
and taking active ownership and
consequences with action so how do you
balance
leading by example what you're talking
about taking extreme ownership
um being assertive with hierarchy and
respecting leadership because the two
are both they're both important
yeah they're both important and for one
thing you know when people talk about
the military and you think oh
well i was in the seal team so every
seal is just we're gonna take ownership
of everything and and
they're going to they're never going to
say that's not my job and that's
actually wrong
it's wrong across every group of human
beings in the world
they're all human beings first and
foremost and there's people that are
you know in the seal teams in special
operations in the military in general
there's a bell curve and there's some
people at the high end of the bell curve
that work really hard and are really
gifted
and they go out and kick ass and there's
some people at the bottom of the bell
curve and
they're trying to skate by and see what
they can get away with and then there's
a bunch of people in the middle
in various various degrees that that
fall out somewhere on that spectrum
so even in the military it's not like oh
you just do what i tell you that's what
you need to do is just do what i tell
you
um there's there's just they're people
and so whether you're in the military or
whether you're in the civilian sector
you've got to as a leader you've got to
recognize that you're going to have some
people that are going to be going really
hard and it's great to have
those people but there's also going to
be some people that are going to have to
drag along a little bit
and obviously there's some people that
you have to drag along so much that you
can't drag them along anymore and
they're starting to drag you backwards
and when that happens in the civilian
sector that means you know you're
probably going to have to
get rid of them in the military it means
you're going to have to get rid of them
this is actor of course as a leader
you've done everything you can to try
and coach them and try and mentor them
and try and get them up to speed
so you know leadership is leadership
regardless of where you are whether
you're in the military working with an
elite group or whether you're in the
civilian sector
it's leadership principles stay the same
yeah that's a good point and um
i think that's actually a really
important point i had a friend who was
in the marines and obviously some
friends
were in the uh the army rangers and they
said yeah you know it's it's not exactly
what you think it does we're not a
monolith and one of them actually told
me who was a i think a former
navy seat from a long time ago and he
said back then he said we didn't spend
much time on hand i can't hand combat
everyone thinks i can kill you five ways
to sunday he said
i learned taekwondo with a 50 pound
backpack he's like i didn't learn how to
fight i learned how to shoot
and i appreciate it again that kander
was oh okay and then afterwards it
became a brazilian jitsu black belt
after the military
um early on in the book you detail um
a story from iraq in which friendly fire
occurred
tough story to read about for people who
end up reading the book highly recommend
it again it's called
extreme ownership i think it's available
everywhere books are sold and probably
audiobook
uh i don't know if we can get andrew
clavin to do an audio book on that that
would be
it would be soothing it would it would
just smooth over the rough parts but as
i did i did the i did the audiobook
myself and late baby we did the
audiobook so
i i assume that you did but the really
intense parts andrew clavin has a voice
that's just
it would make it sound soothing enemy
fire and you're like oh wow this isn't
so it doesn't sound half bad
so this was a friendly friendly fire
incident and as a commander in charge
you did something that a lot of people
wouldn't
um you came forward and took full
responsibility
for the situation which to me was very
striking why'd you do that jacko
well it was it was a tough thing it was
a tough thing to come to as a tough
thought in my head and as i talked about
in the book
as i was trying to you know this
horrible situation took place there was
all kinds of people to blame whether
they were
some of my guys some of the soldiers
marines we were working with whether it
was the iraqi soldiers we were working
with we were all working together
and there was plenty of mistakes that
were made and it was definitely
a situation where i could have pointed
the finger at at many different people
and many different
mistakes that were made and as i went
through this because you know my
commanding officer they're doing an
investigation they're trying to figure
out who they're going to blame
right and as as i'm sitting there trying
to figure out who i'm going to blame and
who i'm going to tell my boss oh
you know is this guy's fault i i
couldn't
figure out i couldn't figure out who i
should be blaming for this and there's a
reason why i couldn't figure out who to
blame
because as i sat there and grilled over
in my mind i realized that there was
one person and one person only to blame
and that person was me i was the
commander
i'm over all in charge of the mission
and
if something isn't done right that's my
fault it's my responsibility
and that's what i did i went in before
my commanding officer and before my
troops and said
hey guys this was my fault and and
here's the important part
or the other important part is this is
my fault and this is what i'm going to
do to fix it
so a lot of people once they read the
book they say well if i take if i take
ownership of something then it just
disappears but and that's not true
either but if you say
yeah that was my fault and then everyone
was like oh okay great it was his fault
now we can move on
no actually that doesn't fix the problem
right you have to actually take
ownership of the problem then you have
to take ownership of figuring out what
the solution is
then you have to take ownership of
implementing the solution so the problem
doesn't occur again
so it's it's not as easy as taking
extreme ownership but the first step
is definitely a challenging one and
again goes back to ego
for me i had been in for you know 15 or
16 years at the time
and you know i had a good reputation as
a seal and i've done a good job
and i've been to combat and all of a
sudden i'm saying hey this horrible
thing happened which
in my opinion a fracture side a friendly
fire incident is about the worst thing
you can have happen
and for me it was a real blow to my ego
to step up and say hey this was my fault
i'm not going to blame anyone else but
at the same
and there's one piece of it where in
in in a leader's mind they think oh well
if i take the blame for this everyone's
going to look down on me and they're
going to lose respect for me right
but the the opposite is actually true
when a leader says hey look
here's what i did wrong these are the
mistakes i made and this is what i'm
going to do to fix it
people actually gain respect for you
because they really realize that you're
not going to shirk your responsibilities
well i think maybe that brings us back
to a point you were talking about before
were there some people who might need a
little bit of of prodding along dragging
along
and there are some people who you just
can't drag necessarily anymore so i
think at that point the people who can
be
developed they'll respect you more but
like you said the people who might just
have to be let go regardless
it may fall on deaf ears and that's a
skill in leadership that you also have
to be able to determine you know the
people whose minds you can change the
people who you can lead and
there are some people some people who
can't for example we've been out and
people
tried to bomb our van because of our
opinions we're like well well hold on
we can change this lady's opinion uh the
transgender who works at juiceland
wanted to slash my tires
maybe let's let's let that sit for a
little bit um
let me ask you this do you think too
that obviously doing brazilian jiu jitsu
and
in combat sports and that's very
different from traditional martial arts
where it's
kata and not full contact uh i've
definitely learned in my life
it it breaks down ego because you just
get your ass kicked so constantly i tell
everyone it's good for a man
to get his ass kicked at least once and
it sounds like false machismo but i
mean it do you think that's played a big
part in your humility
it absolutely has and that's one of the
things about
brazilian jiu jitsu for sure because you
can be a 225 pound guy and roll in there
to a to a jiu jitsu academy and if you
don't know any jiu jitsu
literally a a woman or a 130 pound or
135 pound woman
will choke you out and there's nothing
you can do about it
and so it is an absolutely extremely
humbling
sport to be involved with and it's the
same thing with boxing it's the same
thing with wrestling it's the same thing
with muay thai
if you don't know what you're doing and
you step into the ring or the cage or on
the mat
you're going to experience massive
humility because there's nothing you can
do about it
and i i it definitely helped me it
definitely helped me
it made me respect other people as well
because you don't know who you're
dealing with in the street right you
don't know who that person is
and you might be you know you might be
running your mouth to someone that can
actually
crush you in a fist fight yeah and so i
think it's great for people to do and a
lot of times you know
i've written a couple kids books too and
i obviously in the kids books i
encourage the kids to
work out be strong and know how to fight
yeah and
i don't think it's as popular as the
fold-out tick-tock went the clock it may
not be the first book kids reach for at
bedtime
yeah well the the funny thing is is i
was on uh i was on an interview with uh
npr okay and but yeah exactly
and the funny thing was was they were
they were saying
you know well there was a lot of people
that the guy was really honest with me
and he said you know there was a lot of
people that were concerned about
having you on this program and having
you talking about you know
turning kids into warrior kids that's
the name of the series the book series
the warrior kid a lot of people were
concerned about turning people into
warrior kids and
and teaching them about about fighting
and and
and being stronger and what people don't
realize is that
when a kid is strong when a kid is
confident when a kid is when a kid knows
how to fight
yeah they're much much less apt to
actually get into a fight or to get into
trouble in general
right so yeah or at the very least they
believe
you know this is one thing actually my
good friend henry gracie he teaches a
bull bully proof and he was on the show
to talk about it and he
he said listen you can't solve the
problem with young boys
about you can't solve the self-esteem
problem without them knowing that
they're not gonna get their ass kicked
says they don't have to be the best
fighter they have to be the toughest kid
but almost all of the solutions right
here from principal is you tell them you
stop this
right now you walk up in that bully's
face and you say you better stop it or
else what
if the kid knows he's gonna get his ass
kicked it has no teeth like a parent who
makes it to three
and doesn't do anything and the kid runs
rough shot over them people don't that
is an important point
knowing that you can handle yourself
changes the way that you carry yourself
um i'm surprised npr didn't like you
coming i wonder if when you walked in
was a jawline and a cleft and they said
we have a problem
he's different from most of us you know
i will i will i will give uh respect to
them because they brought me on it was a
really fair interview
the guy had a good good conversation
with me i was i was happy to expose you
know that
to a new group of people and to to the
theories that i believe in and
and the the interview went well and it
got a lot of listen
so i'm fine with it on a serious note
did you develop the cleft and the
jawline from years of badassery or did
you just come out of the womb
with this oh i got issued that once i
joined these yes
just give you a buzz cut like a kiss
from a badass angel
um let me ask you this so extreme
ownership is obviously a concept that
anyone can apply and you talk about that
in the book
but um i do wonder this and our our
mutual friend tim kennedy he was talking
about this on joe rogan's podcast where
he said it's harder to get into the
military today
than in college that a lot of people
just think it's take anyone and it's
their last effort he said that's
actually not the case
he got a lot of blow back and he was
effectively saying that the military
tests for a lifestyle versus test scores
in other words he was saying you can't
i think his actual words were you can't
get off the couch eating cheetos and
smoking pot and expect to get into the
military
but you can in college as long as you do
well in the test in that subject
so let me ask you this considering right
now that there are kind of two camps the
camps of professors and feminists
teaching this idea of toxic masculinity
in which
any kind of assertive leadership
qualities are vilified and then in
contrast
with the equally kind of subversive faux
alpha
male pickup culture do you think that
more young men specifically aren't being
raised today in a culture of extreme
ownership that's a problem at this
moment in time more than
before well i'd say it not only applies
to young men i
i'd say it applies to young women and
young people in general
and and that being said i have to say
you know i still do work with the
military
and the young kids that are coming in
the military right now the young
millennials who have a really horrible
rap they're they're awesome guys and
they're going to go crush it overseas
and they're going to take the fight to
our nation's enemies
and so there's definitely a large group
of people that are that are being raised
right
and going to defend the country and
at the same time yeah there's there's
definitely i mean
is there any question about what you
just asked me really i don't know i was
gonna say it almost sounds like you
disagree with me for a second and i was
gonna have to say well hold up hold on a
second there jacob those are the guys
who've made the cut who you're seeing i
mean they thinned the herd quite a bit
before they get to you
they don't put you before in the first
round audition you're kind of a callback
yeah no but i think i think you can look
around at what's happening with
sort of you know you can look at jordan
peterson you can look at your show you
can look
like my podcast yeah um the the
people are listening to it people are
buying extreme ownership people are
buying my kids books
uh that that's what's happening my other
book discipline equals freedom
field manual it's about like
getting after it that's what it's about
it's about taking ownership of your life
it's about working out it's about
learning how to shoot it's about
learning martial arts it's about working
out early in the morning it's about
being disciplined
that's what it's about and that book's
so sold awesome
yeah and so i think i think while we're
seeing uh
i i think while we're seeing the one
side the people that are saying you know
you ever it's everyone else's fault
which is basically the people that
you're talking about hey
i didn't get what i want to be in life
because of these following reasons but
it wasn't my fault
and there's a there's a number of us in
the world that are saying actually well
it is your fault and when someone says
to themselves
okay did i not get into college because
they didn't like me because i was
x y or z or did i not get in college
because i didn't work hard enough and
get good enough grades and that's why i
didn't get in
or if i didn't get in the military did i
not get in the military because
they don't like me or they don't like
where i come from or do i not get in the
military because
i'm morbidly obese and and i smoke pot
every day like
that's going to be a problem so but it
is it is also beautiful
according to the billboards i will say
this that what you talk about a lot
discipline equals it does it equals
freedom you know as someone
i've struggled a lot with adhd my whole
life and i mean this as a kid they
thought i was learning disabled for a
period of time
i had to learn in french french canadian
it's it's a whole different story but i
was also very dumb
uh but i also didn't know how to i
didn't do well in a class i couldn't pay
attention
i couldn't sit still and um i did later
on in my life i was i was never very
i wasn't as productive in writing comedy
in in in doing as much stand up or
accomplishing what i wanted to
and when i structured my day so much you
know got up early
gym this time lunch this time and i
would put in windows
where i could free flow all of a sudden
because of the safety that i'd created
with this box of discipline
i felt more like picture it like pong as
how i described to people
i'm free to bounce around in here
because i have two lines otherwise i'm
just going to bounce off the screen and
never come back
and i think a lot of creative types
resist what you're talking about because
they think they'll
lose their creative edge when in fact
it's the opposite
yes the complete opposite the the
example i always use with that is jimmy
page
from led zeppelin and jimmy page you
know before he was in led zeppelin doing
what he does with a guitar which as you
know is completely insane
he was a studio musician that was
playing the notes were dictated to him
really complex and he did that for years
yeah and so
if you want to have the freedom to rock
out led zeppelin style then you
have the discipline to practice for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
hours
to get to that level and it's it's the
same thing with any
it's you know it's a creative in a
creative world it's the same in
a regular business structure it's the
same in a team it's the same and in your
individual
life it's the same the discipline that
you have in all those categories will
give you freedom in the end and you know
actually another a good story for you
for when you're doing these business
seminars i don't know if you've ever
read alice cooper's biography
but alex cooper was an addict and was
obviously a crazy person and change his
life
he's a scratch golfer now he's actually
like the best golfer on the pro-am tour
but he actually before every single show
he lists his routine
and he said i realized that i was kind
of rushing russian russian just rushing
along the day and then going and out
going on stage and i wasn't giving my
best performance and so what he does
is he goes into his green room uh he
takes
uh 30 i think 30 or 40 he outlines it in
his book a 30 or 45 minute nap where he
said i shut off the lights
it doesn't matter if i sleep i shut off
the lights no one is in there i get up
i have one chocolate chip cookie i don't
know why
and i watch kung fu movies while i put
on the alice cooper makeup
and p and then i get into characters and
they would do this routine every single
show it may sound odd to us
but that's extreme discipline for alice
cooper i mean when you think about what
he used to do and he's doing as well as
ever
um okay speaking of which what would
your top three examples
uh be do you think of extreme ownership
men throughout history or a couple that
come to mind
you know i mean george washington's
right up there you know he could have
walked away at any time and said look
we're going to get up against the
military that's too strong and too
organized and too well funded for us
and we're just going to give up abraham
lincoln same way
you know i mean there's plenty of times
for him to say okay you know what
where where this is too much and you
know he fired all kinds of generals and
and kept driving forward to to make
things happen
um you know my favorite
military leader is actually a guy named
colonel david hackworth
who was a he was in the korean war he
was in vietnam he wrote an incredible
book called about face
and he was one of those guys he's a very
controversial figure
because towards the end of the vietnam
war
he got interviewed and he was he was one
of the most decorated soldiers at the
time in
in the army and he went on an interview
and he said um the way we're fighting
this war we're not going to win it
and and and the army you know the army
they they pushed him out of the military
in a matter of weeks and he was
blacklisted for many years
but as we look back at the vietnam war
we see
that he was right and he was one of the
few guys that had the
the intestinal fortitude to stand up and
say look the way we're doing this is
wrong
and so i think that person that stands
up takes ownership of the situation
regardless of what it's going to mean
for their personal outcome
is uh is a good leader to me you know
what i was going to george washington
immediately comes to mind and i know
people say oh that's so cliche and i go
on a second
a country that left the world's greatest
superpower ever the the british empire
to become the world's greatest
superpower ever
that's never happened before or since
one century that occurred and george
washington i think important to add to
what you just said you know
could have walked away at any time uh
was facing a very powerful military
and it's also just as important he
walked away when he had all the power
and people didn't want him to walk away
talk about ego that's a guy said this is
consistency with my position
and what i believe this office to be
that is why george washington is right
up there with me and then on a personal
level teddy roosevelt i'm not a huge fan
of him necessarily politically
but if you look at his life the
strenuous life and how sickly he was
as a kid um i think is a good example
okay final question for you then i know
you have to
get going again it's extreme ownership
people you can buy it wherever you buy
books i don't even need to some people
say hey
amazon barnes whenever you buy books buy
the book um
my grandfather was an air force fighter
career was a
colonel uh high-level military service
and transitioned to you know the
civilian sector and it was
kind of a challenge for him and i know
you work with a lot of people like this
how are you able to navigate from an
environment with with the most
serious of stakes you know life or death
or help people
like my grandfather to them the business
world or or the entertainment industry
as you're doing how do you make that
transition because
i know it's got to be a a hard one
sometimes and a
bit of a kind of leveling off and
figuring out the levels of intensity
it's it's
not everyone can do it yeah well being
in the business world
being in the military in the first place
yes it's very intense you have a great
mission
and you're very driven to accomplish
that mission the stakes are very high
and in the business world i tell people
all the time because people ask me the
same question you know how can we come
at it with the same kind of intensity
and when i tell people in the business
world especially business leaders is
looking in the military where we're
dealing with lives but in the civilian
sector
you're dealing with livelihoods and you
as the leader of a company
you know if i don't do the right thing
and make the right moves and i don't
stay humble and make things happen and
get aggressive when i need to get
aggressive and back off when i need to
back off
well i've got 20 200 2 000
employees that are counting on me to
make the right decisions
so they can feed their families and that
is a heavy burden and you know it might
not be the exact same burden that you
get as a leader in the military where
the actual lives of your men are at
stake but in the civilian sector
you know if you what is life what is
life life is hey i'm going to take care
of my family i'm going to i'm going to
feed them
i'm going to give you know give them a
roof over their head that's what i'm
doing as
a human that's that's my goal if i take
if you take that away from me you've
kind of taken my away my life you've
taken away my life with it and that's
problematic so there's
pressure on both sides and and that's
why being a leader
is is a hard thing to do there's a
there's a heavy burden of command
in both situations as opposed to you
give a roof over the head as opposed to
bill cosby who'd answer that give
give a roofie over their head that's a
problem so we don't want to be like him
either not an extreme ownership guy bill
cosby
um but no i i think that's that's
important to know you know what
i have having yet running a business
myself and employing uh
gosh i know a dozen of 15 people and
my wife's father my father-in-law
employs about 50 people
it it really does change things it's
it's like a family and uh
they have to look out for people who
they provide for
effectively these people rely on them to
make a living and they're not looking to
harm those people and they've had to
make some pretty tough calls
people who people who they really like
you know my father-in-law had to make i
remember some decisions that were really
really just torturous for him
um okay this book is extreme ownership
the author is j well let me get your
twitter correct here uh is it it's
jocko will link two l's l-l-i-n-k the
podcast is jacopodcast.com
uh jocko i know that you're gonna get a
lot of young men who are going to read
this and are going to be inspired
and you're going to get a lot of young
women who
are simply going to want to get a phone
call back from you so you know be ready
for that
they can run that through my wife and
four kids uh i think that they'll
probably try and find you directly our
female fans are very aggressive
we've turned the tables on al gore and
used the internet to our advantage if
you like this video subscribe by hitting
the subscribe button or the notification
bell next to it because
subscribing isn't enough watch one of
these other videos and uh you know
listen you can
you can stick around you don't have to
but here's the thing the fact that
you're still listening to me saying
stick around
as i say stick around and you're
sticking around we just added another ad
you just made me for more sense